mark when did you leave Stockton
California when you grew up let's see I
left when I was 19 years old and I was
he's 19 1990 and so I was actually moved
to my friend's sister down to San Diego
and we all drove down to like you know
she was gonna go to San Diego State and
so she had a summer class that she had
to do it at Community College so we got
her into her apartment signed up at San
Diego State and then we went to junior
college to sign up for this summer class
while we were there my friend and I were
in line with her and like hundreds of
people in Southern California signing up
for classes a lot of them in bikinis and
the shorts and tan and sunglasses were
like is so much nicer down here than in
Stockton so as we got closer and closer
we decided we were just going to sign up
and so we signed up for classes went
around the corner found an apartment put
down the deposit and then we drove back
to Stockton and I came home and told my
dad so moving in moving to San Diego he
just looked at me like you're crazy I
was like yeah and you know we just got
apartment owned the whole story's like
and maybe he'll grow up then and then
like walked out of the room like what do
you mean I'm grown up you know at the
time I just thought like I knew more
than he did of course at 19 and as I was
getting closer to leaving he reminded me
that my car insurance is paid by him
which is no longer gonna be paid by him
and that you know I have to pay for gas
and then I had to you know all the
things that I just taken for granted by
you know living with him for so long so
so yeah and then when I moved to San
Diego because I wanted to be close to LA
if I ever got a chance to like act or
direct or something at least I'd be
close to LA wasn't actually moving to LA
because that seemed too scary but this
was the perfect safe way to get down
here sure
and then he left and you turned up the
Pearl Jam and so what was your life like
at that time so you're 19 is he a year
out of high school I'm assuming yeah
well and you know so my life was I was
turning one year sober at the time so I
basically had a very rough high-school
post high school
drug and alcohol addiction and had
wrecked you know almost eight cars and
you know pushed my family away and so
that last that year from eighteen and
nineteen was getting sober building a
life back relationship with my family
again so that's why with my dad saying
that comment was part of it because I
was really like a 15 year old still like
just meant mentally and so I was I was
just ready for a change and wanted to
like take some bigger risks in my life
because I basically just gone to
meetings for a year and said I should
just go down and do that and so yeah so
when I moved down to San Diego's you
know as a culture shock for one thing
and and also a great place for me to be
going to meetings because there's a lot
younger people and San Diego than it
wasn't Stockton Stockton there was
mostly you know these old people like
dirty and and in San Diego there's much
much younger group people so that sort
of built a foundation for me to to
really work the program which it really
wasn't working in Stockton sort of like
that a young kid and yeah so my life so
moving down was a totally different you
know what wasn't just like oh yeah
everything's good it was like oh yeah
I'm like trying to figure out how to be
part of society that's not you know
causing problems
sure and well freed me if this is too
personal but were you afraid that maybe
you'd be tempted just because you know
Southern California is much different
from Northern California in some parts
and there's a lot of opportunity for
many things definitely I mean I naively
thought I wasn't gonna have a problem
because I thought I was sober everything
was fine but once I got here it was a
different story once I got here then I
realized wow there's you know it's a
different world there's more it felt
like there was more drinking in San
Diego there's more colleges there was
more you know beach town different
things like that when I got down when I
was on my 21st birthday you
I was like I should go to a bar she'd be
able to like be able to get ID'd and go
to a bar and you know and it was I went
with a friend
sort of like stupidly and you know went
to the bar and was like looking around
had a coke and I was like what am I
doing here like this is not a safe place
for me to be and so we left and you know
I'm still sober today's today it's just
coming up on 31 years this year Wow so
so yeah it's you know it's it's been
just life you know but yeah I feel like
that I feel like I was naively thinking
oh it's gonna be fine but it has
challenges it definitely had this
challenge there was definitely feeling
like oh wait a second maybe I'm just in
just a phase I was going through but I
have enough experience to know and went
to enough meetings to know know my
experience is different than other
people that just had a couple beers sure
yeah
so you felt safe in San Diego because
the industry was like two hours away
yes but eventually you you moved closer
yeah yeah so I was sort of telling it
was ballet I had like six jobs so I was
like barista grocery clerk ballet and I
was talking to you know girl that was up
smoking a cigarette like the Symphony
Hall selling tickets and she was saying
she was going to a wrap party I was like
oh yeah who's the rapper she's like no
no a wrap party for a movie that's being
shot here I was like oh cool it's like
I've always wanted to be in movies and
stuff and be an actor and director and
stuff she's like oh cool you know I'm
like walked away and then a couple days
later she came back she was out smoking
cigarette and you know walked up asked
her how you know how everything's going
how was the party she's like I was
gracious and she my friend does props
they're looking for somebody if you ever
you know are you interested and I was
like it was such a random thing like I
didn't say I wanted to work props I
never said I wanted to work in the
business they just said acting and
directing and so I said yes so it took
this meeting with this assistant
she said well we're looking for an
intern it's a three week shoots shoots
here in San Diego if you're interested
here's the script the prop master wants
you to read it three times first time
just read through it second time reads
her and highlight everything that's a
prop and then on the third time write
down anything that you think would be
needed by the prop Department in a scene
and I was like okay and she's like and
can you have it by tomorrow
so I did so I read this three times I
made all my notes I showed up at this
hotel and it was like had they had the
whole floor the hotel the whole
production it was like the production
office art department props
grip electric and me was just like chaos
on this whole floor like doors open
people screaming like ooh someone's
throwing a script quick quick get this
out to the actor noon Teamsters are
arguing about stuff and I was like oh I
love it
I'm home chaos like controlled chaos and
so I met the prop master and he looked
at my notebook and I tried to explain to
him like what I did isn't you know you
your assistant said things like uh-huh
did you really like read this three
times and I said yeah because nobody's
ever done it I've had 50 interns over
the last 30 years nobody's ever actually
read it three times no one's ever done
this so you got the job if you want it
he's like technically it's not me it's a
job but you're not we don't pay you I'm
like of course yeah yeah no I know it's
intern yeah yeah so called my jobs and
told them that I needed those three
weeks off and I had no idea I was gonna
pay for anything I didn't know anything
it was just like an opportunity it was
just like I need to do this and on the
first day there was a strike the
Teamsters were striking the they were
trying to go Union is a big huge thing
is like in the early time of like the
nineties when all these TV movies were
trying to be flipped to go Union and so
they had left LA to come to San Diego to
do this movie try to stay away from the
Teamsters but it didn't work so on day
two they sign that they sign the
agreement and the assistants had to
leave because she wasn't Union and so
they brought in somebody else who then
left couple days later to go do another
movie and all of a sudden I'm the guy on
set doing
everything and so I went from an intern
to assistant props to assistant prop
master and by the end of the movie the
last week it was just me from the prop
Department because the problem has to
look to do a movie the on set dresser
had to do something else
and so I was the only guy left doing
every department including firearms
which I of course was not licensed to do
but he just handed it off to me he gave
me the proper training but you know they
weren't actually loaded but it was just
still it was still a real hands-on so I
was I was dealing with onset of this 19
year old Wow and when you eventually
been paid because yes yeah on day three
I got I started getting paid Okin so it
all worked out and you know and it was
it was the best experience I mean I
think that you know when I people always
ask me like how like how what's the best
way to get into the business you know
how did you get in and I for me either
if you want to act or direct or write
especially if you want to write you know
or you know even produce to do as many
jobs as you can because you can be on
set and seeing how things get made and
you know I was just talking to a friend
of mine who just produce this movie and
the writer they kept saying you know we
have 14 days to shoot this it has to fit
into 14 days so limited locations and
they still were not able to do limited
locations and then the scenes always had
like action and they're trying to do it
you know you keep trying to make it
smart once you're on set you realize oh
this is why you can't do it more than 40
you know this is the day yeah these look
if we move get in a truck everybody has
to go park park their trucks unload the
trevor ething takes time was your onset
you realize all those little those
little elements it helps I think every
department you know up and but so we're
not being on set it was great because I
got to see what everybody's job was and
then because I worked my butt off
everybody wanted to help me so by the
end of the movie I was able to go to
everybody and say hey I wanna move to LA
so if you have anything it's a PA or
props or you know teamster driver
anything let me know and so I had all
these people that said they were and
help me
after the movie of course as people go
not every single person helps me know
but I had enough I had enough people
willing to take my call and and help me
get some some job so within within six
months I was packing up my Nissan Sentra
and you know moving up to do this movie
for six weeks and I haven't never came
back
so I'm making back to visit but I packed
up my stuff and you know moved up to LA
probably two months after that at the
movie so did you move right to Hollywood
or did you go to like North Hollywood
where was a little safer so when I first
moved here I moved into Mar Vista area
like just right outside of Santa Monica
because the after the end of that movie
I had no place to live
and because I was sick the ironies is
like I had one friend in LA and she said
I could stay at her place so I came up
here I texted her well it was paged her
hey Jose yeah I left a message on her
voice mail
and then paged her when I got into town
she said stay here and then she
never returned my call so I showed up
and I'm like sleeping in my car at the
production office on the first day and
they go what are you doing and I was
like well my friend she didn't you know
so I got to stay the production
coordinators house for the whole movie
but at the end of it I needed a place to
stay so the medic on the job was like oh
I've got this extra room my friend just
moved out so you can you know rent my
room so I end up moving there and was
there for about six months and then got
my own place in Los Feliz I was there
for probably five years and then moved
to mid-wilshire and then it was there
for a long time and now I'm in the
dreaded Valley as I thought and now it's
become in heaven Toluca Lake I'm in
heaven
Oh Bella Italia Jason no belly light
real estate for me exactly at what point
did you then go in front of the camera
or decide that you want to direct like
you so you're working with props you're
working more behind the scenes and then
when do you get to be in front of the
camera so it was 95 and I was working on
the chamber which is a film with Jung
Grisham novel with James Foley who
directed it
it was Gene Hackman and Chris O'Donnell
in it and so we were shot in LA but then
we traveled to Jackson Mississippi who's
about a guy on death row and he's like
there was it worse Lee successful to
John Grisham novels and films adaption
of the novel and so we were on I was on
set and the I was on I was assistant
prop master and then a friend of mine
was the on set dresser and we were
always you know hustling to you know do
this job we were doing you know working
really hard and the director you know
sort of saw that we were you know young
and hungry and you know so he wanted to
sort of be friends with us because we
were like always joking having fun and
stuff and so he at one point you know
took the the the walkie-talkie said it's
not cool you guys all get to talk on the
walkies but I don't so we gave him one
of our walkies and he said there on the
walkie changing channels talking to the
assistant director talking to the key
grip and everybody's like why is the
director on on the on the walkie you
know he's not supposed to be to let
leave him and to do this thing but it
just became this this this great
relationship and on set he was just you
know asked me one day is like so what is
it you want to do when you grow up I was
like well you know I like props you know
I think you know do a couple more this
is a prop master and maybe I'll get to
be a prop master and he's like man like
we mean now he's like now you're you're
too good like you don't care like I can
tell you don't care about the job but
like you're good but you know it's not
what you want to do there's like oh well
he's like don't tell me
but he said successful people know what
they want to do and they write it out
they set a time when they want to do it
by and they put amount of money they're
gonna have in the bank and then they
just do it and then they tell everybody
that's what they're doing I was like
okay so next day I'm show up on set and
he asked me did you write it down
like no now I thought about it but it
was such a confront like you know it was
like the first day on set I was like
watching actors like oh this is awesome
you know like I get to see what they do
it's like oh yeah I want to be an actor
then I saw the director giving
directions on directing is cool too
and then it's like oh the gaffer
lighting setting up the shot there's
like so many things that I like to do
but it's just like it's so scary to be
an actor to say oh I'm gonna be an actor
now like I think I'll just stay as a PA
I'll just stay as a driver I'll stay as
a prop guy that's just safer and it was
good money and so it was like you know I
don't remember like on my second movie
an electrician was you know literally
the time I was not smoking but like it
hung out with smokers apparently cuz he
was smoking by the truck and he was
saying he's like yeah man you gotta be
careful cuz the money is so good you
don't want to leave so whatever it is
gonna do man you should do it because
you're gonna get sucked into this and go
paychecks good and then you do another
movie and then it's another movie and
he's like nah that's not gonna happen to
me so here I am on set and talking to
the director so the next day I wrote out
you know I want to be an actor writer
director producer I'm gonna start doing
it after this next movie excited the
movie lined up right after I'm gonna
have $10,000 in the bank and I'm gonna
do it on December 1st 1995 so I came in
the next day and I said so I wrote it
down I want to be an actor writer
director producer he's like okay he's
like actor worst job you have no control
over anything writer you get no credit
producer hardest job and you get no like
nobody cares what you do it's just
you're responsible for everything he's
like director that's the job he's like
hey man whatever you want to do but do
it did you now wrote it down and so I
did I literally had that I had a movie
right after his doing this movie the
volcano here in LA and so I that first
day that I started I knew I was gonna
finish on December first
and I told everybody I told the first ad
at one point and she ended up getting me
apart has this rookie cop and I got to
get my sag card I told the producers
within the print while we were prepping
so when we were shooting when the
producers Neal Moritz would walk up to
me and say so what do you think should
we break for lunch or should we just do
a walking meal you know all those kind
of things would just sort of I would
tell people this is what I wanted to do
director I talked to him and asked him
why he picked his shot I mean I'm doing
my job it's not like I'm that guy just
like hanging out so people were were
open to talking about that and then I
finished that and I literally took off
six months and I started an acting class
I took a directing workshop at AFI I
started writing and did a workshop
through which used to be film and not
film independent it used to be something
else in the house find and and then a
producing course through AFI as well and
so I remember I remember uh showing up
at a film independent event like three
months after that you have to have a
little tag on your thing and this is you
know what you're when you sign up like
what your profession is so I thought it
was like I'm well what am I here for I'm
like actor writer director producer so I
wrote that all down and I met this guy
he's like oh man so what have you done
and I was like oh I thought this is just
like what you wanted to be when you grow
up like I didn't I didn't know and he
and I are still friends to this day like
we are still we still talk we're still
on Facebook you know connecting with
each other but he was just so like no
that's not how it works you got to be
doing something like why I mean I'm
saying I want to do this so how else
will people know if I they don't know
what I want to do so I mean it and
that's a whole nother story for me it's
just sort of like how hard it is to say
you want to do more than just one thing
because you know people really want to
just go but yeah but what do you really
want to do you know what is it we have
to focus on one thing and so I just just
listening this great TED talk about how
you can't be great at why you're not
gonna be great at one thing this woman
holing something about multi
like a multi professional like you have
different different eye different areas
of your life like you're a hair stylist
and you also you know a violinist you
know somebody that does multiple things
which is what I think I am so got way
off track I'm Mike white on your
question but no no it's an interesting
journey that you you've taken us on so
with that director did that set in
motion you writing things down that
challenge oh yeah absolutely yeah
absolutely so that that really pushed me
into realizing that I had to you know we
have some accountability to what I
wanted to do so I end up getting a white
board and you know writing out my goals
all the time it's something I do I still
do to this day I'll write out I have a
friend of mine that's sort of like an
accountability partner we email each
other Monday Wednesday and Friday we
sort of these are our goals for the 90
days actions I'm taking towards each of
these goals here's what I'm doing this
week and you know just kind of ups mine
my game because it's so easy to get sort
of stuck by myself sitting in front of
my computer like how am I supposed to
get from A to Z and so and then it's
also great because there's like sort of
markers of like oh I'm getting there I'm
getting closer to you know the end of
the year it's not like you know I didn't
what I do this year it's like I did a
ton of stuff I used to the last couple
years before I just had a baby for me 14
months ago so I did my wife did but they
only thank Jeff in and so but it is my
office is now his bedroom and so but on
at the time I hadn't painted the one
wall in my in my office
chalkboard black and I started writing
down you know at first it was just sort
of projects and things updates things I
was doing then I was getting frustrated
and my projects weren't going where I
wanted them to go so what I did was I
shifted that and I just like we were
going on vacation that's like I'm just
end of the year I was like I just had to
clean this whole wall if I'm just these
projects I'm just so frustrated because
I have like 25 projects and like I can't
control any of the stuff that's on this
wall it's just so frustrating so we went
on vacation and I came
it was like a blank wall and so I was
like well what-what can I not I don't
want to put anything on there that's
just just to put it up there you know
cuz I was getting ready to have a
meeting for something one of our
projects and I was gonna put it up there
and I was like man instead I put God's
will which sort of like I'm the universe
whatever you whatever you want
I'm just gonna put it up there and if I
get something if something happens a
meaning if something moves forward then
I'll write it up there but I'm not gonna
sort of put my intention visit all the
things I want and so sort of don't know
why I thought of it don't know why I did
that but what ended up happening was
every time I got a meeting every time I
got an opportunity every time I met
somebody every time I had an audition at
booked something you know project was
moving forward wrote something whatever
those things were finished an outline I
had to write all those things on the
board and so at the end of six months I
was like oh wow this is like a lot of
stuff is happening and then by the end
of that first year it was so clear to me
that I've you know I didn't know any of
those things were gonna happen so like
the day before those things happened I
had no idea
now I had like intentions of like all
the things that I want and what I want
from my career in my life but the
specifics of you know how I was gonna
get them I had no idea so sort of like
this weird thing of like how do I get
from A to B I don't really know how it's
gonna happen I know that I want B and so
I take a ton of actions I do a ton of
sub that's risky and then we'll see what
happens and out of that all these things
sort of polish over here shines over
here and so at the end of the year I was
looking like holy God like my life is
huge like I've had this something an
amazing year and it wasn't none of those
things were things that I could have
come up with so like if I had said here
are the things I want to me want to be
directing at Capital One commercial I
want to be directing and Nissan Heisman
spots with you know these amazing and FL
football players like I couldn't
couldn't my aperture of what my
possibilities were was like this but
when I just sort of opened it up and
went I don't know what's exactly gonna
happen but I want to be directing I want
to be writing I want to be producing I
want to be acting these are the things I
want to be
with these kind of people this level of
people and this thing happens so I did
that for two years and we had the baby
and so it's just like I had to like
clean it up but it was such a huge thing
for me and actually miss it
I've missed it this year and I was
thinking about it
actually this morning domain on there
right we have a whiteboard that's behind
our no my my wife and I share an office
and it's behind one of our sliding doors
but we haven't put anything on it we
didn't land I don't want them let's see
what we'll do what kind of maybe we'll
do something different this year and
it's you know it's just like oh he's
alive we have to keep him alive I
thought it started like our goal right
now is that you know and so but I was
thinking ah there's so many things
happening just from yesterday that I
would love to build like oh I didn't
know that was gonna happen oh this is
really cool isn't happening so I wrote
him on my notebook I was like I might do
that you know later on today what if he
wants to become a screenwriter and I
produce well you know whatever he wants
to do I mean we basically were talking
about that because somebody was talking
one of our families like showed you guys
have a college fund set up for a more
like wow yeah but you know he doesn't
want to go to college he doesn't have to
go to college neither of us went to
college you know and you know at the
same time we're saying to school like
just you know we had a perspective of
school we have one now and it's like you
know we want him to have as much
opportunity as possible and as much
knowledge as possible we don't want us
to force him we already tried to force
him to like eat when we wanted to eat to
do what we wanted to do that's not
working so I don't think it's gonna be
successful when he's and you know I'm
graduated from high school so we just
really want to try to if he wants to be
a screenwriter if he wants to act if he
wants to you know if he's you know wants
to be a hairstylist he seems to want to
help her do her makeups and maybe he'll
be a makeup artist you know so yeah
whatever he wants so well I know we were
talking earlier and and about you know
safety and and there's no real safe
route especially post-recession
I think a lot of what maybe our parents
generation thought was safe the norm was
one thing and there was always that you
know my grandparents generation get it
you know job of the pension and since a
lot of that safety is not there
anymore I think it's it's like kind of
like just she said like whoever's will
yeah it's you know yeah I think so too I
think that it I think it was more times
have changed so much he used to be I
mean just that was how it used to be it
used to be a very simplified way of
looking at things and now I mean I had
so many friends that parents had lost
everything and you know the market
crashed they had all this money in their
house then they went underwater and they
had nothing you know and so it was just
all their savings was like oh well we
have it equity in her house and then
when that went away it was like there's
nothing and so there is no safe there's
no like I'm just gonna started a bank
teller and make it to bank manager and
bank it's probably the wrong thing cuz
of course they're you know banks always
win the big banks seem to never get
arrested or anything so they can you saw
the big guys nothing happens they just
renamed them babies renamed exactly just
buy another bank another yeah sure
change laws yeah exactly you had sent us
an email I guess we're on your email
list and so you don't send out emails
too often I think you do it kind of
sparingly and you had an article in one
of them that's the title was surround
yourself with people who hold you to a
higher standard than you hold yourself
and so we're kind of just that lends
itself perfectly what does that mean for
you
it means it's easy to be around a whole
bunch of people that are miserable and
you know frustrated with their careers
and so they will tend to be in their own
stuff and so I try to do my best to
surround myself around people that are
trying to better themselves that are
doing the risky things that I want to be
doing so that when I can when I'm
feeling down I can call them and say for
example I just had breakfast with a
writer producer friend of mine who's on
a TV show and I had sent him an email
sand is so funny he didn't even remember
responding to the email that was sweat
like it's just his life is so busy you
can think so but he responded but I had
said so I
this pilot that I wrote I got a ton of
notes from people I did those notes I
feel really good about it then I got
notes from this one person and it's sort
of a rewrite like bigger rewrite but I
have in the my process I got this other
idea and I'm thinking this other idea is
better than this other pilot so do I do
this rewrite on the pilot or should I
start working on the new show and so he
wrote back oh man how many times I've
been in this position finished rewriting
the pilot and then go to the new story
and so it was that kind of thing and
then he had sent an email couple weeks
later
hey checking in did you start working on
the pilot and he totally forgot he
checked in he forgot that he had worse
my mean he remembered after I told him
but it wasn't something like he was
walking in but so for me trying to
surround myself with people that hold
themselves to a higher you know calling
and higher you know a sort of
responsibility that helped me and so and
that's how I am with my friends I'm you
know I studied with Milken Seles of
Beverly Hills Playhouse and one of the
things he used to say when people were
late to class he would say man
do you have horrible friends in this
class to the person that walked in and
usually usually the person like what do
you mean looks like well I find him your
friend I would have like walked out you
know before you got here and called you
and said where are you why aren't you
here your friends aren't holding you
accountable they're not helping you and
so that was always something that like
you know that I want to try to be he
said it's more difficult to do that with
friends and you can potentially lose a
friend because your music are you
willing to lose a friend to help them
and to help them be better and I think
that's what you know I try to be I'm not
perfect with it they're prime sure
there's friends of mine that I should I
could push more or support more and at
the same time you know I'm not doing
everything I should be doing you know
I'm not saying I'm perfect but I'm
saying that how I can support and uplift
some people around me you know it's I
think it's important I think he's just I
think it's my default is not to take
action my default is really to you
find what's wrong with what I'm doing
and sort of just stay in this like
hamster wheel of like it's not working I
don't know what to do how do I figure it
out and that's why what that wall like
before it had all this project so I sit
there and go trying to figure out how it
was gonna get the right person to read
this script or you know take this
meeting instead of just going okay I
have this project now what are the
actions I can take okay here's the
emails of these five people done do
these things great alright so I did that
and then what else can I do today I
guess I'll go to the beach or go have
lunch or you know my wife and I will go
do something or now it's like oh right I
have my hour and a half to do something
and then he's up and it's like okay you
got him no okay great Alfie I gotta well
let me just play the devil's advocate
here because um I think it's great that
you have that desire to want to be
around people that are gonna hold you to
a higher standard or maybe they're
further along but then there's this
thing in LA where sometimes when people
do achieve things it's almost like a
magnet and then people go away and they
get kind of like left to their own
devices because maybe they're not at the
same level and they feel bad about
themselves you threatened so find that
interesting that you want to surround
yourself with either people they're
gonna hold you accountable or maybe
people that have maybe a few more
credits or whatever and you feel like
that's beneficial because I don't know
if everybody thinks that way and I hate
to take a negative turn with it no but I
think that's a very big thing in this
town oh yeah I mean I feel like there's
a there's a lot of people that you know
don't want people to be successful that
means they feel very limited that's my
limit I feel like it's limited to think
that if you get something that means
that I that there's nothing left for me
if you get that thing because there's
just so many there's so many
opportunities there's enough work for
everybody there's enough for everybody
and so I think it's hard for people
because you're fighting for you know
even asking for help from somebody I
mean it's hard to ask for somebody go
okay can you introduce me to so-and-so
that you know
if I'm trying to get a project with that
person it's a that that happens a lot
and so sometimes it's like oh yeah
that's an easy thing and other times
it's like I know you have a project
that's very similar to mine so I am no
situations I will usually be honest and
say if it's something like that I'll say
look I would love to but right now I
have this project and I'm trying to get
to them as soon as that's dead I'm more
than happy to sort of get that but I
can't with all the other people that are
involved in this project I don't feel
right to just do that and then other
times like the director that I know is
trying to like get into this prove with
this producer I've already gone
everywhere I can with this producer you
know to network with them if I can get
this woman a job why does it hurt me if
she can get a job so I do the
introduction and you know it doesn't
hurt me and I find that the more I'm
willing to help people it always comes
back
there's just just at whatever level you
know I think that's the I think it's
it's hard for me to understand when
people ask for help and you can see that
it's you're so selfish and so
self-centered that there's no there's no
give anywhere there's no like let me you
know if you needed something I would
help you and be more like you know help
me with this thing because I heard you
know the thing compared to well yeah I
don't you don't have anything to offer
me but I could still you know it's like
where's an exchange of at least a thank
you of a real thank you instead of you
know or whatever okay cool thanks you
know kind of thing
yeah it's knowing it's knowing when
someone's more of a taker and yeah but I
get that but I guess just I find that
refreshing that you want to be around
people that are gonna hold you
accountable or or that you can kind of
aspire to or whatever you know you've
done so much already but I think that's
great because that sometimes that's not
always the attitude and it's not just
that someone thinks that you've taken a
job for me it's just they haven't gotten
the job they wanted right and so it's
too painful to be around someone that
they perceive everything's going away
yeah absolutely and and I think that
there's two things I do have a group of
friends that have
have gone away while I've been
progressing in my career now my career
still not where I want it to be but just
there was there was even a time when I
got to do my first direct my first
feature there were two people that like
just were there in my life but they I
could see they pulled back like there
was something about what they sort of
their decisions were sort of taking him
a different road they were the ones that
were way more talented than me I mean
both of them still are both of them are
better directors better writers like I
think they're better but they sort of
get in their own way and you know I
found myself having to pull away because
there was no sort of like the love
wasn't you know like I wanted them to be
as excited as I was for them when they
had things happening and it wasn't and I
was like oh that's interesting
and now you know this is you know about
four years later and it's like those
guys are not in my life anymore and it's
tough I mean I try to keep trying then I
was at one point is like I'm the only
one texting take this take a look what
do you get you know what I mean and then
they'd meet and then it's just like yeah
you know it's just like Oh where's the
no excitement for what we're doing
together you know so it's tough it's
time in this business I mean it's brutal
yeah that's I guess where I was trying
to say it's not just brutal in going on
auditions or pitching whatever but then
the relationships around you and that's
something that I feel like people don't
explore a lot and you know I think it's
that's great that you you put that in
your gear in your email
can you recall a directing producing
acting job where not only did it teach
you the most but you saw someone that
you said I want to emulate myself after
this person I liked the way they handled
the crew I liked the way they spoke to
someone or it could be a negative and of
course you won't we don't have to
mention friends either way but you knew
in that moment like this is actually a
life lesson
you just didn't made me know it well
maybe you're doing in the moment maybe
didn't but it was something that really
changed you in terms of the way you
wanted to approach something could have
been the director that asked you that
challenge do you really really did
challenge like what are you doing you
know you're young but time you know
there's been a lot of that I think first
person that jumps to my mind is when I
was starting out I was as a as a driver
on the set when this movie called a home
of our own with Kathy Bates and Tony
bill was the director and Tony bill was
an actor and Wow a long time ago and
then start directing and so what I loved
about him was he just he came on set and
like everybody was just this it was just
peaceful like he didn't you know it was
like a lot of chaos with kids there's
like eight kids at times and and he was
able to just just handle everything with
ease and he was it was really great and
like he knew everybody's name and I
thought that was just like you know he
saw me at the you know after like week
two or something and said you know I
opened the open the band or good morning
mark
done then God and I was like ah he knows
my name he knows people's names and so
that was always important for me and so
I saw that for myself it's something
that I wanted to do either as an actor
or director of producers like I wanted
to know people's name I wanted to know
what they did and wanted to make sure I
said hello and and then the next one was
when I was doing a small part is at
bartender notions 11 opposite George
Brett Pitt but George Clooney was there
that day and he has in the scene he
walks behind Brad Pitt and that day was
I was walking just from my hair makeup
to the set and George was coming and he
was walking with his assistant
and some grip or something it's a Tony
how's your son doing it looks like you
know he's like good alright good hey how
you doing I'm George you know introduce
himself to me is that was you know was
walking with the ad and and they're just
like that was something that and I
stayed on set and watched him and Brad
you know do a scene together afterwards
and I saw him take you know a mountain
dew I can as he's talking to the
Wardrobe guy music uh-huh okay great
oh you need me and they walked away and
the Wardrobe I looked down and he had
poured the whole Mountain Dew on his
shoe while he was talking to him and
then he was like this practical joker
but he knew everybody's name he was like
talking to everybody I mean whether it
was the grip electric craft service me
some guy that was coming in for one day
and I thought that's the kind of you
know that's what I want to have I want
to be that kind of a you know a leader
in on a movie and so on every month all
my productions I'm really trying whether
it's just one day and I do that even
when I'm doing art directing on
commercials or you know a promise or
still I'll do commercials and stuff and
all I know everybody's name and at the
end of the you know job I'm saying
goodbye to everybody it just it just
helps it just like it just makes the the
projection better and makes the day go
by easier when I'm asking for you know
an extension cord you know I know who
the person to ask I know the right
person I know his name you know it's
just that little bit and we're like oh
we're a team not just hey you can you
and and that definitely makes a
difference when I'm directing I just did
this movie and New Mexico and the crew
had all worked together before and so I
come to the you know it's just the DP
and I were the only ones from LA
everybody else was all local and and for
us to come in and just you know even on
the prep days to see how they work and
how they do stuff you know it was
different than the way I was used to but
I was able to you know adapt and find
ways to you know get what I needed and
give them what they needed for me and
and by the you know the end of the first
week it was like oh this is like just
like it is you know and I was getting
those sort of communications from like
the line producer production managers
saying wow you really you know
put us all in our places at times and
yet you know we see how hard you're
working like that was part of my thing I
was like I'm gonna work just as hard you
know and that was the production
designer would had told me out of the
first week he goes he came to set and he
said so never had anybody never had a
director be in bed after me sending me
emails and up before me responding to
emails Wow
and and that was what that says that's
my job I should be the one first one in
last one is that's that's what I should
do and so because of that he was doing
he was willing to do work extra hard
people were willing to cuz everybody's
on the same same thing it wasn't like oh
I'm just because I'm the director I'm
you know some the boss it was more of
like at least I'm the guy that has to
like say yes no yes no yes cut you know
I had to be that guy and I have to be
responsible for that so beyond that if
you can be the best at your job you
bring your everybody's the best of their
Jobson like then I can win so that was
something I saw Tony and George do is
like I felt like they were a lot of
other directors to Soderbergh does that
mean
surberg Darlene gives direction to his
actors he's really you know he
communicates with them but it's you know
he's casting the actor that's gonna
deliver the thing so it's more about the
scene and what they're talking about
buddy isn't going hey give me a little
bit more doesn't do any of that stuff
it's it's more camera works more about
let me try something else let's do it
whatever you want
and same thing respecting crew people
and you know so that's sort of what was
my sort of inspiration too and I feel
like that fits my DNA as a person anyway
I'm there too you know that's my dad's
like that and my dad and those people
and those everybody in town and wants to
help people so I think as a director
that was something and even with it was
acting even I'm banned away it's like
being that guy that's like I co-wrote it
I'm cruising it I'm you know I'm in it
like it's I have to be the guy that's
leading it and if I have a crummy
attitude everybody else is gonna have a
crummy
so I really had to step up and even when
it was not going the way I wanted it to
go I had to be positive I had to you
know find solutions rather than we have
problems you know yeah yeah that must
have been interesting so you're like you
and the to it
you're the LA guys that got you no no
these to LA and then trying to fit in
where they've already established
relationships and all that yeah they had
certain way to check off boxes and
certain thing this is how we do this is
things I really would love if we could
you know can we look at a couple more
locations because this isn't quite what
we had talked about and you know and
that's tough for me cuz I want everybody
to like me so if they you know if they
say no that's it then I had to still go
okay but come have one more is there
just one more location that we can look
like cuz this is just it's not fitting
you know sort of my references and it's
all about story so I'm trying to explain
it's like the story she just shows up to
this place it's not that scary and if
it's this place is way too scary we're
all the audience why is she walking in
there so there's like this fine line
like okay and then once we found that we
found a building and it was like you
know it wasn't exactly what I wanted but
it was closer than these other two and I
thought okay I'll give a little bit so
that we can you know and so little
give-and-take and so it was a nice
little thing where they're like okay we
appreciate you giving us if we know this
is not exactly it we'll see what we can
do about this car that you want and so
there's always that sort of negotiation
you know how do you know what
protagonist is someone you want to spend
time writing a script on spending years
with the film or the webseries becoming
that character if I'm still interested
in doing it after any length of time you
know it when I'm reading it if I'm
reading a character you know that's
something that's one thing if I'm if I'm
creating the character if I'm as a
writer and I'm doing that or it just as
right or just writing for me as an actor
if I get frustrated early on the process
and just go like I don't care don't care
about this stuff like it's very easy in
there and as I'm reading or as I'm
working
this project I was just piled that is
working on I just found myself like not
getting excited about it and I was sort
of trying to fit
I had heard these people were looking
for this sort of project and so I sort
of kind of fit it into what they wanted
and like I don't want to play I don't
want this character like Wieck who cares
about this character that's would be
some redeeming quality there has to be
something that's not even redeeming
quality there wasn't even cause just
like it was more about I feel like I'm
getting older like what is it they
really want to you know leave behind you
know if I'm creating something you know
it's not just you know I mean yes I want
to entertain and you know and I'd like
to you know inspire people and like to
make people you know have some sort of
you know go through an experience but it
is just gonna be something and that's
just you know some piece that like
nobody cares about or you don't care
about the characters afterwards and then
why do it you know but it is it is I
find I find it when I'm when I'm writing
you know especially that I'm just or if
I'm trying to read the script and like
my page 25 if I'm not into like well I'm
not interested like I really want to be
able to have some when I have a hook I
want to find some something some journey
that the character is going on whether
it's from you know you know down on now
to up or they're good and then fall you
know but I want to find I want to see
some something that that makes me go oh
yeah I can I can relate to that I can
you know I'm interested in that you know
with this the DeLorean or who you know
turning this other documentary I saw
about the woman who doesn't blink the
yeah oh yes the Thera knows oh yeah yeah
that was great
oh my gosh you know what I mean I'm so
interested about why she does what she
did it how she you know I really truly
think she was trying she believed that
she was gonna do good that's what I'd
like to think yeah this got away from
yeah it does when somebody just like all
of a sudden oh oh
shoot how am I supposed to do this so
since you're an actor when you start
writing a story are you automatically
starting with character are you starting
with a theme for the most parts
character and for the most part that's
what gets me in I'm looking for you know
people that's what I connect with
sometimes I think the best I was saying
there was like a story that somebody was
like interested in and so I was trying
to fit some characters into this story
and it was like not it was ringing false
to me cuz I did I wasn't believing the
characters I wasn't believing who these
people were so for me as an actor is a
you know starting for me as an actor I
feel like I'm sort of moving away from
acting as being mine like main thing
that I love doing as much as writing and
directing feels like the more creative
freedom and doing what I love do to do
to tell stories and so so it really does
come from the kid from for me as
character so as I'm you know as I'm
writing I'm definitely coming from okay
who are these characters what are their
relationships how do they you know how
do I find some personal connection to
them and oh yeah this is like my mom or
like this is like you know my dad this
is like my cousin you were who's that oh
that's like Milton he's reminds me of
that so I'm finding those pieces to make
it as authentic as possible you know
it's so deaf that comes from character
the stories you know sometimes the the
overall things becomes plot again it you
know that sometimes is like I have to do
first character work first and then I
can get into okay now I can find the
problems like okay that seems to work
itself out more when I go who are the
characters what are their problems what
do they want once again into that it's
like okay now I can list 12 different
ways to get her in trouble you know
these are the 12 ways rather than
there's the one way that I think in my
mind oh yes she gets arrested for
shoplifting now I'm like trying to make
a character get to that rather than well
she could get shoplifting she could you
know relapse she could you know you know
get arrested for being black at the
wrong time I mean all the different
things that could happen
so it's not just the one one thing that
happens based on the plot things so I'm
definitely coming from character as much
as I can and just because as an actor
I'm reading something and I'm trying to
connect to that so how am I gonna act it
like it's not just you know it's not
just words on the page because I have
friends of like work right amazing prose
but I don't know how I would act any of
that stuff because it's just it's so
like in the head of the kind of thing
this is interesting but it's not active
all and it's not directed well it's so
you know sort of becomes clever that
doesn't feel real and authentic I'm not
talking like cleverly the Coen Brothers
because the Coen Brothers clever and
genius and real at times you know but
then other times it's like it's just a
lie slightly heightened but we're all
there long because there's something
about those characters we can connect to
and you've written two things about con
men is that right or just one just one
okay maybe there was a something you
were directing I'm sorry yeah yeah and
so when you started writing the banning
way with your was a cooperator okay um
did you have the initial idea or did he
so he had originally had a script about
a con man that was sort of like the
Italian Job F feature and so he was
working on that and we were in acting
class together and he came to me is that
you are perfect you're just like this
character that I'm that I'm creating and
he's like when I'm gonna show it I want
you to read it like you tell any actor
that you're writing apart like I'm gonna
read it I'm gonna tell you it's great
like that's that's like cuz I want to
get I want to work and but he wrote a
really great script but it was too
similar to Italian job there's and had
time job it just came out it was one of
those things like Oh can't he just can't
do that but but I liked the character
there's something about it that we both
connected to and so that's sort of the
process of like well maybe we'll do a
short film about this character you know
and and yet when we first started we
sort of were banging our heads like oh
the short film is not really gonna do a
bank robbery if there's like it's a lot
of money to get like you know to you
know shoot at a bank that's closed down
and you know all those different things
yet dressing and stuff and so it just
became
we should do a web series and once we
started thinking of something outside of
what he was writing then we realized
we're like okay well who is this
character what is this world and that
really was where we got to take this
character and then bring sort of you
know together like a lot of my story
about you know dad who's a cop you know
an uncle who's sort of a thief like I
don't have an uncle as a thief but I had
a lot of you know men that were older
than me and construction I worked with
that were stealing and selling drugs and
that kind of stuff right under their
brother who was a cop and so I had a lot
of those things and my struggles with
sobriety and those kind of things that
had happened so I was bringing a lot of
those personal stories into it and I
think that's and then Jesse brings his
you know creative and his his own story
you know to the to the character and we
were able to you know search shaped his
character then and build out the world
and who these characters were and I
totally lost track of you were question
ask anybody this is just sort of a side
question why do you think we love to
watch especially like lovable con people
you know like grifters are very like
we're seeing it but these different
mostly women that have like posted on
social media it turns out they've had
like a you know they've been living off
of someone's credit guide but in were
all fascinated by it's like very scary
because we wouldn't write to happen to
us but we're fascinated as a culture by
sort of charming grifters yeah I would
love to know exactly why that is - but I
I think there's something about when
there is so many like there's the right
wrong like we know what's right and
wrong and so I feel like most people for
the most part are living in a safe place
and right you know we know we probably
shouldn't steal the stapler from work so
we're not gonna steal it you know but my
daughter really needs a stapler for a
class whatever it you know I mean and we
just don't do it because we just like we
don't do that it's it's stealing right
but when you see a character then steal
the stapler to go bring it to her
daughter you're like oh that's
interesting
see I wanted to do something like you
know I think there's something about
we're so
you know as a society supposed to be
doing good so when somebody does bad I
mean there's enough people doing really
bad right now so we're not talking about
that but in that in a fun entertaining
way I think we can sort of suspend
reality and go oh that's sort of you
know an escape into that kind of world
actually I was thinking of the movie 60
seconds with Nick Cage where they're
stealing all the cars and they have like
60 seconds gone in 60 Souls that's what
it is and I was thinking like that's so
interesting that they're all car thieves
stealing cars but somehow they we've
justified that it's okay that they're
stealing cars you know the cops are
after them or but there's something
about the excitement of that even though
we would never well I own maybe you
would steal cars I don't that way if it
was a Tesla Tesla yeah but yeah other
than that probably not I like Tesla's
yeah never dude won't be able to afford
one but yet so Jesse came to in acting
class that I have a part for that's
perfect and then what was the process
like writing the script cuz you were
putting in your own sort of flair to it
whether it's personal or imagined
stories well so he brought me the script
and then I read it and I said this is
great it's very similar to the tie-in
job and this needs like yeah I know I'm
thinking about reworking it and then
literally nothing happened like six
months go by we sort of do our own thing
that was ace read I gave him some notes
and sort of he was doing his thing I was
doing my thing and then in class and I'm
acting and I'm doing all these scenes
that were that Millman had signed me
because I was having issues really just
like owning myself as an actor like
owning like I can do this I can have a
career sort of frustrated with I wasn't
really breaking through and so I was on
this journey of two years of breaking
through taking really big risk as an
actor and so at the end of this period
it was like six months at the end after
that thing that was a script that I was
realizing oh man like I'm feeling really
good like I can't get a job and then
we're a world like it's just not
happening and so Allan Barton was
teaching that night had said to my scene
partner she was frustrated with her
career her sister is very famous
she felt she was better than her
as an actor and yet she couldn't get a
job and he said you know you've got to
build your own door and walk through it
forget her thing forget her journey
you're on your journey and so he was
talking to her but I heard it and I was
like oh man I feel like in that moment I
was like I'm worried so much about
getting a casting director to call me in
or you know write the right agent to
like you know to submit me that I should
just be making my own stuff like I
hadn't been directing and making shorts
with whole bunch of people in class and
we got into film festivals and you know
we were you know talented we had enough
I knew how to production and you had to
do every job so it was like why am I
wasting my time waiting for a casting
director to call me in a director that
cast me let me make my own thing so I
went home that night and on my
whiteboard I wrote today I stopped
fighting and so my wife Brienne who was
in my girlfriend the time I said I just
feel like I'm like I mean you know
pulling the door I got my foot in the
door and I'm like trying to get in like
you know somebody casting me and no one
used to say you know get into the party
like however it takes to get them to the
party and so I feel like the parties
they're pulling on the door trying to
get got my foot in the door and the back
door is completely open and my friends
are there filmmakers they're like mark
come on in it's great party's great
there's free drinks is free everything
like I don't drink now but I you know I
was like no I really want to get
somebody validation I need the
validation from the business before I
can go into the party and so I just let
that go and then that morning I wrote
down then I can where I wrote down three
three director writer directors that
wanted to work with me and Jesse was the
first person on the list and so I
reached out to him and said hey you know
you know you had this script and you
weren't really sure what you're gonna do
with it which you have meet me for
coffee and let's just talk and then that
was sort of like so I want to do
something for myself I want to create
something you know maybe there's a
version of your script that we can do
maybe it's a short film which is then
started as talking and then we decided
that the short film was gonna be
expensive we kind of got a budget from a
friend of mine it was like $35,000 or
like just for a short film so that year
I went to Sundance with the short film
that I had acted in
and there was literally six people in
the theater and there was the four the
five screenings maybe twenty five people
total I met a ton of people at Sundance
but at the screening like there was
nobody for short film like nobody shows
up those late night you know midnight
you know short programs but I had a
friend there that had made the movie
himself a feature himself and you know
it was like $100,000
and made a deal for international for
DVD and Home Video and was gonna make a
million dollars like over five years
like all those money was gonna come in
it's like we should do like a feature
like do it independent and then we can
sell it as a DVD we can raise some money
you know like that's the way to go and
so as we started to work on that then
the web series our web world started
happening and I saw these web series and
they were making some you know making
it's like okay looking but they were
also making money I was like well what
if we do web series sort of feature type
of thing which is funny because kwibi is
doing that right now that's what
Katzenberg is doing with kwibi it's
basically short form content that's
going to be a feature which is exactly
what crackle was doing and so we didn't
know that we didn't know what we were
doing at the time we just like what it
started with
we're doing a feature expensive then we
thought well there's web series that we
could do a web series then then we
thought how do we get paid for web
series and so we and then we were trying
to figure out writing a web series like
how long is the episodes like is it you
know can it be long can they be sure I
get everybody says got me short no
they'll see longer five minutes is the
longest all these different things are
like how do we you structure a story in
five minutes and three minutes kind of
thing and so it just sort of was like a
natural thing you're like okay well if
we did it as a feature that's the you
know we know act 1 act 2 act 3 and then
we cut up act 1 into six parts and then
eight parts for act two six parts rag
three there we've got our series right
there we've got a web series and we got
a feature film that we can sell on DVD
and home video if we you know make money
if we can you know finish it and that
was sort of the process
and so once we sort of figured out sort
of our box we also work backwards
because Jesse was like video game guy
loved playing video games I liked cars
he also let we both loved you know sort
of the conman type of shows he written
that and so it just sort of as a natural
thing of like okay so this is the world
and then we we really we talked about
this a lot is that which is challenging
at times but we sort of knew at the time
there was even the best things we found
out what the box was like okay it's
gonna be feature it's gonna be something
that we have to be able to make it's
gonna be for eighteen to thirty-five
year old males they like video games
they like girls they like fast cars they
like you know action sequences okay
great so that's our that's our box now
we can start to fill in who these
characters that fit that box so we were
already thinking how we gonna sell it
instead of let's just make some cool
project that you know cuz he'd already
written a script here he wrote a feature
that is hard to make so you know had
like seven minis that were you know
running around the streets of underneath
LA and so we can't do that we can't
can't it's too expensive so how do we
kind of create this thing and so that
was the process of us figuring out what
the world was and and then I mean at
least is structured and then we got
together pretty much every day for six
months like in between you know acting
auditioning classwork photography I was
doing a shooting head sauce at the time
I was propping and you know getting
together every day we'd get together
with like okay from four hours at some
point we would get together we would
write we would talk about story the
world read books watch movie watch the
TV series that were similar to it and
and then but the end of that six months
we had basically a first season you know
arc we knew what the characters were we
had the pilot and really like the first
we called the pilot the first two
episodes we're splitting them up so we
had basically a principle for each I
mean again it starts build you're like
oh we can have a principle which sort of
binds these two episodes together we can
have
ten episode we had twenty episodes we
have ten principles one episode he
follows them second one he doesn't and
we get to see how that happens in each
of these episodes and so those are all
things that we would get together and
figure out what pieces work with pieces
don't work and it was a lot of work it
was really a lot of work where did you
get the production budget for this I
mean cuz it's high-quality this is not
like yeah I know you said you you look
at other things you thought well this
looks more amateurish that's not how
this looks this looks incredibly
professional well yeah well what we end
up doing was we finished it in the six
months and then we sort of drank the
kool-aid thinking oh what people are
gonna love this thing and like they're
gonna buy this we're gonna be able to
put together you know business
proposition we could put a whole
proposal together we got budgets we got
this whole thing we started meeting
people some private investors some big
agencies and everybody passed it was
like us wait too expensive like nobody's
gonna make a web series for this money
you know it's just I think it was like I
think we had heard that somebody would
make an episode for $50,000 in episode
can I think so we put that number down
and then and then once we got sort of
six months of vibe doing that we're like
it's not gonna work like no one wants to
buy this thing is just too expensive
they like the idea but it was just too
high concept for the places that we're
making web series at the time and so we
said well we're both depressed
well usually were one of us were up and
one of us down but we were both sort of
depressed at that time we were both like
he just hit again a wall you know where
you know a guy an agent at ICM had said
to us you know it's like no offense mark
but you're not Clooney and you're not
Soderbergh so no one's gonna like just
give you guys all this money so we're
both depressed I'm in Atlanta shooting
some photos for a magazine and that just
hit me it's like why we should make it
ourselves like let's go at least shoot
the first two episodes it's like a pilot
and then we can show is like a
proof-of-concept and we can cut a
trailer and we can you know get it to
some people because right now they
didn't think we could do it for little
or money then you know
instead of it being like a three million
dollar thing so we did we put together
what that would look like put a budget
for those two episodes and you know and
Jessie's wife was very successful and
was like I'll help you guys support
listen figure out how we're gonna make
this so we put down the money together
we figured out how I would make it I
think it was like twelve thousand
dollars we put together for this you
know three days shoot and if we got a
car from Jaguar like I reached out to
them I got this car so we shot this
episode these two episodes cut it
together and cut a trailer together and
then we had started putting it together
a website which is basically like now
would be like a pitch deck for the
series but as a website so since we
thought it was gonna be a webseries it's
gonna be on the web we created a website
we had like the character page we had
like the world we had you know what the
synopsis was with the what the season
one arc is how we could brand it how the
brands could come in and you know you
know that being there from the car to
clothes sunglasses to all these
different things and we put the trailer
up and we send this out to like that
email list that you were talking about
and at the time you know I had maybe you
know 250 people he had maybe 250 people
and we sent that out and said this is
what we've been working on here's the
trailer we're still working on two
episodes but you know if you know
anybody that might you know be able to
help us get this made let us know first
call I got it was like 20 minutes after
we sent the email and it was ICM
assistant calling for my friend Jesse
Alpert and so I called Jesse and this is
the guy that said I'm not cleaning and
he's not soda Bert and he said this is
great like this is great he's like I'm
on my way to NBC right now can I pitch
it to him I was like wait what Wow I was
like yeah yeah yes and then he came back
and he said they loved it and can I
pitch it to crackle tomorrow they're
looking for basically what you guys have
which is his web series last feature
film
and that began our thing so we Bissell
met all the studios in town love and
networks and crackle just seem to mean a
they got us they figured out they they
got us as as creators they believe in
the project and they had no problem that
I wasn't Clooney and he wasn't so very
vaguely you're a perfect we don't want
to recast and no you're perfect and
other people like were you open to
having other people you know potentially
and we said no he's directing I'm in it
that's that's how it goes and so between
NBC Universal and cracklin we end up
going with crackles felt like that was
like the best home for us and and so
that's why it looks so great is that we
end up you know pitch it to them several
meetings we got like okay there should
they want to do it they want to budget
now we'd already gone through budgets of
stuff and we're like okay he said if you
can make it for this money they'll say
yes so that's what the our agent told us
so we knew the number and now basically
we try to fit and we said okay we can do
for that number we talked to a friend
and put together budget she's like yeah
that's a lot of money for what you guys
are doing I mean it's not like a lot but
like yeah we can do that so we said
here's the number and they said that's
great that's what we can do and so six
months later of negotiating it's the
same deal the same thing and we we got
the green lights you start writing it
because we had basically six episodes
written we had the first season but we
hadn't written the whole thing out and
they were glad they did because they
wanted to be able to work with us on
sort of the the idea and and so we
worked another five or six months on the
scripts with them getting it to where
they said they kept me just don't worry
about budget just like just write the
script right the best movie and so it
was like a you know a process of us
doing a draft getting a budget having
been three times more than the budget we
said we can make it four and I'm saying
it's too expensive so rewrite it and so
we were constantly going back to
rewriting and getting a new budget
rewriting and getting a new budget and
finally we got to the point where they
were like there's no more money than
what you said you can make it four so
like let's make it four this
and it was just such it was a
heartbreaking thing because at first
they're saying make whatever you you
know make it and then something that
kept saying and there there's more money
don't worry about there's more money but
there was it was like that was the money
that we said we can make it for cuz just
he told us didn't say that and we didn't
know any better and it's not that he's
wrong I mean that was the number they
were looking forward to greenlight a
project what year was this sorry to
interrupt ah this was 2009 ah okay do
you think if it had been 1999 and we had
web series then it would have been
different do you think that the downturn
had anything to do with definitely a
downturn definitely yeah yeah it was at
that point it was like they were so
trying to cut their losses and figure
out how to do stuff that everybody was
like uh-huh let's not make too had are
we gonna recoup our money on this and
crackle was just starting out with
they'd only done one other show
previously that was basically a feature
they cut up but it wasn't made that
ready originally but they realized oh
that works we can do these short form
kind of things yeah but it was a totally
different world I mean even like I would
say five years later it was even harder
for them I've had friends that had
projects at crackle that were trying to
get things made and became harder to you
know not even a lot more money to do it
was like there's a little bit more money
than we had for Bannen but it was like
still tough til I get things may cuz
everybody wants like can you just make
it for less you make it for last few
Malia that's what everybody
that's what producers and Studios want
to do because they need a profit but as
challenging as a creative to go you're
trying to you know we had created this
box that we thought and then they just
said oh don't worry about the box like
it can be whatever you want it to be and
then we realized oh no that was not we I
don't even think we heard them correctly
you know when they said don't worry
about budget I think they meant like
write the best movie and we'll trim
where we need to trim you know we have
hard core people we had like you know
twelve parkour guys like climbing
buildings is like no we can't do that so
then once the series was released what
happened what was the reception section
was really great I mean I think that we
were surprised by as many
accolades and views that we got and it
was really at a time where the streamys
were just starting out and it was like
their second season for the Streamy
Awards and so that was something we
wanted to come out in the in 2009 so
that we could qualify and so it became
sort of a there was a little bit of
controversy in the beginning when we
were released early released episodes
because we wanted to qualify just like
they do with the Academy Awards people
released the movie in December so they
can be you know qualified for the awards
and because of our web series was
produced by Sony and by crackle became
sort of like yeah but the web series is
different web series are independent and
so it was within the community it was a
bit of a challenge because people were
thinking Wilson it's a network it's a
studio we're like yeah but we're just
filmmakers and like they gave us a
little bit more money than if we'd done
it ourselves but like where there's
nobody behind us besides you know
they're helping us but we're just two
guys making it film we that's all we are
and but it was well-received it had for
that time it had you know 14 million
views most views anybody had ever had at
that point where for a show now that's
like nobody like 14 minutes nothing 140
million is not even nothing anymore and
but and then we we were nominated for
Wars and stuff with Banff and with
streamys and so yeah we were really
surprised and excited that people were
were digging it and we got to you know
we're at comic-con signing posters and
it was crazy it was such a great time
and and then once sort of some of that
died down did you think that that would
have helped to lead to another project
oh yeah I drank the kool-aid on that too
thinking oh yeah this is gonna be just
natural that I just walk in the door
tell them I did this and be able to lead
to something else it what it did is it
opened a lot of doors for me and I was
able to be able to you know to take
meanings and get things across and
almost get certain things made I did
book a ton of jobs out of afterwards
that you know that I got specifically
because I had done it but it wasn't as
easy as like oh yeah we'll just be able
to make this as a TV series
we should do it as a TV series with Sony
television and didn't wasn't able to get
it made and they're like okay we'll go
do something else and we both sort of
split off and did our own things and try
to get things made and you know I think
that the the business is seductive where
you start to think is is easy like we
just made this and I think I said in one
of my my blog post too it's like it's
easy to get sucked into knowing what how
hard something is so as I'm creating
something I'm thinking oh I know what
they want they're not gonna want this
because they want X Y & Z so then I'm
not going to worry I'm not gonna do that
I'm gonna try to do something else and
so I found myself right afterwards
trying to give them what they want what
different places wanted and not doing
something I wanted and so that's where
we sort of where we started with saying
now I feel like I want to create you
know projects that I'm excited about
things that mean something to me
because those things will get made
eventually or not but I at least
spending time doing that rather than
going oh so ABC is looking for this kind
of show okay I'll start working on
something like that or Cinemax is
looking for this so I'm gonna start
doing you know I can adapt my project
for that and then I just felt like my
was just sort of spinning wheels trying
to you know create something for
somebody else that I didn't believe in
does that make sense it does what's your
advice for a filmmaker between projects
especially one that's proactive where
your your statement is you don't wait
for leap stuff to happen you know keep
it pg-13 but what what's your what's
your advice I you know I feel like it's
easy to get stuck with thinking oh my
gosh this is happening you know like
right now we have a project that we've
been pitching and getting out there and
and you're waiting on phone calls and
you're waiting on emails back and
waiting to see if people are interested
and it it's so seductive that you know
Oh Wednesday we'll hear on Wednesday
those Wednesdays turn into four months
five months six months and you're like I
just wasted six months waiting for them
to call me
you pass you know or happen to you know
we were run out of options so my wife
and I have this project that were the
the specific project that we're going
working on together and literally were
like okay so the minute we had something
set up with a company and we were had a
writer attached so we were like
beginning to you know set up okay we're
now setting up meeting like okay next
thing like we have to work on something
else together because I'm doing other
stuff she's doing other stuff but we
want to work on something else okay what
else we gonna do let's find something
else to do because if nothing else does
that take up our time you know cause
otherwise you're sitting there waiting
once it's sort of added place it just
becomes now we're getting emailing
somebody we're making calls we're trying
to set up meetings we're setting up
pitches and then that literally takes so
long to get a pitch on you know a
meaning set sometimes it's three weeks
to get an answer then it's four to five
weeks to get the meeting most of time
they postpone there's another two three
weeks then you pitch then there's a week
to wait and then it's if it's a pass
normally it's a pass you know that you
wasted almost three months not wasted
but three months you've been waiting on
something when you can be spending time
you know working on the next project so
that's my advice is like you know
there's no you know not that you need to
have 50 scripts in your in your arsenal
but like you should be constantly
working on other stuff so that if
nothing else it just keeps my mind out
of the shooting you check my email
oh I need did this happen because it's
so easy I said it's seductive it feels
that way because it just feels like like
today no man happened yet so maybe I
should send an email to them to see if
the executive heard anything it's like
no we're gonna hear
we'll hear when we hear but if I have
something I can be working on then I'm
constantly creating because creating is
how I got the meaning like it wasn't
just me you know talking about something
I created something that they liked it's
gonna get me to the next thing so so
then going back to the one wall that had
all the projects but this time at the
top of it kind of like this is not my
will yes this is the University well
whoever's will and and but then here are
the projects underneath yeah yeah I mean
I
we have the the projects and the next
steps for those projects so those are
the actions that I'm taking and then
sort of that helps me to go okay so now
I understand you know here in my project
K I've done everything I can for those
like probably some more stuff I get I
probably rewrite that one okay maybe
I'll work on rewriting that other times
it's like okay I have to start fresh
like all these ideas are like the same
ideas I've been sort of you know
reworking for so many years and nothing
is really happening with it let's let's
sort of break free and try something
different let me just try a totally
different genre let me try a totally
different you know character or whatever
it is just to you know continuing to be
creative
what's been your easiest year here in
Los Angeles as a filmmaker and then
what's been your most challenging mm-hmm
let's see I feel like the most
challenging was probably right after the
banning way I feel like I feel like I
had had expectations that it was
supposed to go a certain way and there's
so many meanings there are so many
possibilities that I thought could
happen that just didn't happen and so
there was like a year of like nothing
really working out and like a whole year
went by of just nothing like no projects
that got greenlit no part no acting
stuff it was sort of a weird time and I
think it all again this is what I said
like there's a there's a part of me that
gets seduced by the idea that I'm
entitled now because I've had some
success or like that success of this
will lead to something else rather than
enjoying the process and enjoying like
that's what I did that's what I'm done
now gloves on start working again you
know my wife just finished a series and
you know it's so easy to get sucked into
like oh I'm just gonna get a job right
after this or even when you're in the
job like oh this is gonna lead to
something else and we were in it going
we just be grateful that you're doing
this let's be grateful I'm doing this
because it's not about you know then
getting the next thing based on this
thing because careers are all over the
place I feel like the easiest year that
I had was probably two years ago prior
to Davis being born where I was just
doing tons of action that was just
showing up to what was in front of me
and not really focusing on you know
having to get a meeting or get a thing
and just like oh I'm creating I'm
writing oh I'm okay I'm doing this today
and it just felt like oh yeah it the
flow of just you know like I was saying
that wall of stuff that just kept
happening
and there was acting stuff there was
directing stuff that was writing stuff
hired to bright hired to write the
script hired to produce this thing and
it just felt like there was a like I'm a
balance of being creative all the time
and I could tell you I can't tell you
what I was doing differently
specifically from the year before the
year after except that there was a an
acceptance of like okay this is what you
know today this is what I'm doing you
know I'm not like I have to be doing
this thing this is what has to be happy
I'm not working hard enough I was like
okay I did all those things now let's go
to the beach like glitter let's go to
the beach let's drive out there in
traffic to get to the beach enjoy it and
then drive back in traffic back home and
just like oh that was really nice you
know and then things happen so I think
that those are more recent I'm sure that
I've had other years were you know they
were worse or easiest but those are sort
of examples of me thinking I'm you know
I know
more than and then I guess it's more of
a title thing I think I really feel like
you know a lot of a lot of people feel
like once we've got to a certain thing
you can just you know I mean I had like
I said have this group of friends that
are writers and showrunners and
directors and you know they can't get
their projects made they're getting
postponed it's Cinemax they're you know
get you know wrote a script almost there
with X company on this studio with this
network and there's a one of six that
don't get picked you know and this okay
so it's not just me you know and they're
still figuring out like do I get a
staffing job do I try to sell another
pilot what do I do you know there's no
nobody's ever made it you know there's
like the JJ Abrams and the Spielberg's
but then there's like thousands and
hundreds thousands the rest of us trying
to you know figure out you navigate this
thing and I think it's just you know
it's easy to think that it's you know
once you get this one little thing you
know even just one show it's not in
front of my did he had a show and he
worked in four years it's not you know
it's not it's not something that's
guaranteed you know success of one thing
doesn't guarantee success right after or
even you know it'd be ten years that's
where you have to always be creating and
be okay when you don't have something
and okay when you have something because
you know our life is not gonna be I
don't think the trajectory of this I
think it's constantly you know finding
you know finding a peace and a place of
inner peace throughout this rocky thing
that I'm looking okay this is awesome
but they don't have to get you know so
excited that I'm gonna you know my life
is over if it doesn't happen and then
when things are horrible not to think
it's gonna be like this the rest of my
life not so it is today do you think
being a dad has balanced you out and
that sense I think being a dad has
definitely put focus on less about me
and less about sort of this entitlement
of all this other stuff I think what the
pressure on that I have on myself now is
oh ya know I have an hour to have to
finish something I need to do it like
I've got to write that I've got to
finish this thing I guess in these
emails out because he's gonna be up or
she's gone I have a meeting we both have
a meeting how are we gonna be you know I
think there's that has taken away some
of the pressure of the succeeding is
less has taken away the sort of the and
to hurry up and succeed it was sort of
in my mind way prep and succeed so then
I can have baby you know and we have
that now we know we can have that in
this like no we're not going to ever get
to the place where we want to be to have
a baby let's have a baby now
and now that we have the baby it's like
oh my god she's the most amazing oh we
have a meeting okay cool well okay great
look how amazing you are you know and I
think that's been the biggest the
biggest thing it's like it's not none of
that stuff feels as precious as it used
to be you know I mean you can still feel
upset when things don't happen but the
preciousness is like you know we're like
oh yeah there's this used to be that
with our dogs now it's like now we have
him and the dog and you know